herr schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema belarus
polen und die menschen die dort an der
grenze ausharren wir sprechen über die
aktuelle lage und wie belarus gezielt
menschen auch an dieser eu-grenze
schleust und vor allem sprechen wir
jetzt am anfang mit unserer unserer
reporterin anna falls die ist nämlich im
polnischen grenzgebiet unterwegs auf
bella russischer seite sollen inzwischen
10.000 geflüchtete bei eisigen
temperaturen dort ausharren und warten
dort auf eine chance die grenze zu
überwinden und auf der anderen seite
ihnen gegenüber stehen rund 12.000
polnische soldaten grenztruppen und
polizisten die genau das verhindern
wollen
wir sprechen außerdem mit dem
journalisten thore schröder der sich
intensiv mit dem thema beschäftigt hat
wie boulahrouz also menschen an diese
grenze schleust und zum ende der sendung
sprechender eingehend mit der expertin
im politikwissenschaftlerin olga drin da
war wenn ihr fragen oder kommentare habt
dann könnt ihr jederzeit direkt in den
stream schreiben oder ihr schickt sie
einfach per mail an die adresse die wir
euch jetzt einblenden und beginnen
wollen wir mit meiner kollegin anna fest
die seit dienstag in polen ist ganz nah
also an der grenze steht genauer stehst
du ja jetzt gerade vor dem hauptquartier
der grenzpolizei in biarritz talk und
anna schilder uns doch bitte mal jetzt
gerade ganz aktuell deine eindrücke von
der lage dort vor ort
genau ich stehe hier gerade vor dem
hauptquartier der regionalen
grenzpolizei und wir können hier nacht
für nacht beobachten wie eben kolonnen
von polizisten richtung grenze fahren
was da genau passiert wissen wir nicht
weil wir keinen zutritt haben weil wir
dort in dieses gebiet nicht rein dürfen
das sperrgebiet
die lage soll wohl ruhig sein in dem
lager hier beim grenzort kubica
allerdings hat das
verteidigungsministerium heute früh
vermeldet dass in einem grenzort südlich
von hier ist zu ausschreitungen gekommen
sei da haben migranten wohl
grenzpolizisten angegriffen und seien
warnschüsse abgefeuert wurden die lage
sei unter kontrolle
aber auch das können wir nicht
verifizieren wir hatten heute vormittag
ersten mal die chance mit migranten zu
reden da waren wir zu besuch in einer
sicheren unterkunft ja und das war schon
eindrücklich da erstmals die beobachtung
von diesen menschen geschildert zu
bekommen du hast dort unter anderem auch
mit josef aus syrien gesprochen haben
auch bilder davon von eurem gespräch
heute mittag und wir haben auch von
josef dann einen ton oder bzw wir haben
heuer gespräch das hast du uns
freundlicherweise voll zur verfügung
gestellt wir können also auch in die
schilderung von josef jetzt mal
reinhören der also über russland nach
belarus ist dann an die grenze und wir
haben mal kurz rein was er die erzählt
eine belarussische sicherheitskraft hat
uns aufgegriffen einer hat mich ins
gesicht getreten einen knochen hier und
meine nase gebrochen und meine rippen
tun sehr weh
sie haben uns durchsucht und meinen
freunden geld weggenommen
danach haben sie uns mit einem auto in
die verbotene zone zwischen weder russen
polen gebracht
und uns dort gezeigt welcher weg nach
und wird
an der grenze haben uns belarussische
soldaten den zaun hoch gehalten
danach sind wir aber nicht weit gekommen
nur so 50 meter wegen meines schlechten
zustands
[Musik]
uns haben dann die polnischen
sicherheitskräfte erwischt und uns mit
etwa 20 flüchtlingen zurück zur grenze
gebracht am nächsten morgen haben wir es
wieder versucht und dasselbe passiert
auf der einen seite haben offensichtlich
oder so sagt er die bälle russischen
kräfte ihnen da dem weg zur grenze
gezeigt und gleichzeitig wurde er
zusammengeschlagen wie passt das
zusammen was hat er da noch erzählt
ja das ist eine gute frage also
tatsächlich was er und aber auch andere
migranten erzählt haben ist schon das
eben der wege rüber über die grenze von
belarus nach polen sehr gut organisiert
ist ein mann aus dem irak erzählte mir
davon dass sich gruppen gesammelt haben
und dann gemeinsam mit bella russischen
grenzsoldaten angeleitet von denen die
ausgestattet waren mit nachtsichtgeräten
und funkgeräten und so draht schneidern
um den zaun aufzuschneiden also dass die
wirklich so rüber gebracht wurden und da
einfach eine perfekte organisation
hinter steckt auch dieser mann
berichtete von gewalt gegenüber
migranten durch böller russische
soldaten wie das zusammenpasst habe ich
auch keine erkenntnisse zu es ist auf
jeden fall keine einzel schilderung die
uns der josef da erzählt hat und
jetzt lässt polen ja menschen für die
journalistin journalisten aber auch
humanität nun humanitäre kräfte gar
nicht an die grenze direkt dich daran
glaubst du das hängt auch damit zusammen
dass man da also gewisse bilder
irgendwie nicht sehen soll was ist die
erklärung jemand euch gibt dass ihr da
auch wirklich gar nicht weiter dürfte
gerade
hier die offizielle polnische erklärung
ist dass unsere bilder weiter
provozieren könnten und dass es
sicherheitsbedenken gibt
tatsächlich glauben wir eher dass es
daran liegt dass man die kontrolle über
die bilder behalten will es ist ein
riesen dilemma aber es ist auch für die
eu ein riesen dilemma weil auch
mitarbeiter von frontex bisher nicht in
die sicherheitszone dürfen und das führt
dazu dass es keine kontrolle darüber
gibt inwiefern
menschenrechtsverletzungen stattfinden
oder inwiefern es zum putsch becks kommt
und was ist da jetzt so deine prognose
also wie das vielleicht auch weiter geht
wird die situation sich eher verschärfen
wird das schwimmer hat vielleicht sogar
josef oder andere dir da auch was
erzählt ob da eben noch so viel mehr
menschen gerade sind also was weißt du
das kannst du dir vorstellen wie geht
das weiter in den nächsten tagen
wir haben migranten in dieser unterkunft
tatsächlich videos gezeigt von großen
menschenansammlungen in minsk das heißt
man kann schon also in diese videos
lassen sich nicht verifizieren wie
gesagt wir kommen nicht ran insofern
könnte man schon davon ausgehen dass es
weitergeht und lukaschenkos strategie
scheint ja aufzugehen also die eu ist
unter druck lukaschenko will dass die
sanktionen gegen ihn aufgehoben werden
das werden sie bisher nicht die werden
im zweifel nur noch mehr verschärft
insofern wäre meine prognose schon dass
das noch weitergeht
noch eine frage zum schluss an dich anna
mercato bei youtube fragt warum werden
frauen und kinder nicht durchgelassen
also die frage an dich ist es so hast du
also jetzt auch er keine frauen und
kinder dort gesehen die durch gelassen
werden
wir haben in der unterkunft heute eine
hochschwangere frau getroffen sie war im
neunten monat schwanger hatte drei
kleine mädchen dabei sie haben es
geschafft über die polnische grenze sie
erzählte aber auch dass sie nicht gut
behandelt wurden also dass es keine
keine nahrungsmittel gab das ist kein
wasser gab dass die umstände ihrer
flucht hier nach polen sehr sehr widrig
war und dass sie keine bessere
behandlung durch belarussische soldaten
erfahren haben als männer
danke an erfasst für den moment du bist
auch jetzt in den nächsten tagen noch in
der region weiter unterwegs und wird das
ganze für uns weiter im blick behalten
danke für den moment und
wir haben gehört und werden jetzt auch
noch mehr hören dass also die menschen
die dort teilweise eben an der grenze in
belarus stehen und da auch rüber möchten
nach nach polen und weiterziehen möchten
im zweifel auch noch dass die auch aus
ganz unterschiedlichen teilen dieser
welt kommen und dazu haben wir uns
eingeladen thore schröder er berichtet
für die sz aus der arabischen welt wir
erreichen ihn in beirut und er schreibt
eben er hat einen artikel geschrieben
eine große recherche gemacht für die
süddeutsche zeitung mit dem titel minsk
connection darüber wollen wir gleich
mehr sprechen guten abend thore schröder
und der grund warum wir unter anderem
auch sprechen ist weil das ihre
recherche gezeigt hat dass also menschen
teilweise organisiert von beirut so weit
weg da wo sie gerade sind also auch nach
mainz gebracht werden können sie uns
dazu erstmal ein bisschen mehr erzählen
was hat das damit auf sich
ich höre sie gerade nicht herr schröder
das soll nicht heißen weil vielleicht
aber können andere sie auch nicht hören
ich frage mal kurzen die regie kann nur
ich thore schröder nicht hören oder
können wir alle nicht hören
jetzt kann ich sie wieder hören okay wir
versuchen es noch mal was ist das genau
was sie daraus gefunden haben in ihrer
recherche
letzte woche noch in deutschland
manchmal längere zeit gar nicht über nun
wohl ein kleber seit zwei jahren war
dann bei der gelegenheit als in
deutschland anderen eisenhüttenstadt war
ja da die erstaufnahmeeinrichtung ist
für flüchtlinge nie ein weitestgehend
aus bloß aus polen kommen und da war die
mehrheit der leute kann ich sagen war
wachsen aber auch ein paar server mit 2
1 habe ich gesprochen die sind relativ
problemlos durch den wald gekommen
sprechen vom wald also das anders grenze
so damit ich nach bonn gereist und habe
hier mit einem freund zusammen mit einem
syrischen freund zusammen das ganze
prozedere
recherchiert wir sind dann zusammen die
küstenautobahn nord hochgefahren und
sind das
spezialisiert ist auf reisen nach kairo
und
der freund von mir ist der rein und
haben sich bereits interessierte
besucher vorgestellt und daneben dann
die preise
mitgeteilt
rundum sorglos liest das mal ganz kurz
abh er alles nicht habe
also für 3900 4200 dollar topf
kommt man da visum eine eigene
einladungsbrief und den den flug muss
dafür pass abgeben zwei passbilder und
genau weiß was ich muss auch dabei da
gibt es glaube ich hier in der gegend
also in beirut und lang mindestens
dreijährige spezialisiert reisebüros man
kann aber auch direkt zum
honorarkonsulat der von globus
da kostet das paket
einladungsbrief und wieso 1500 dollar
das ist dann aber
wieder an meinem freund mitgeteilt das
flugticket das könnten sie dann auch
noch dreimal die woche direktflüge mit
der
weißrussischen staats-airline pilawa von
afrika nach mit
da wollen wir gleich auch noch mal im
detail auf diese einzelnen wichtigen
punkte eingehen also diese spannende
recherche die du da gemacht hast vorher
schauen wir uns auch noch mal an
moustafa aus dem irak den haben meine
kollegin luisa thum und mein kollege
herr sandra show getroffen ist nämlich
auch über so einen interessanten weg
also nach deutschland bekommen sie haben
heute in halberstadt getroffen das ist
so ein bisschen parallel deckt sich so
mit dem was du erzählt dass da hören wir
kurz rein und dann reden wir nochmal
weiter
ich bin vom irak nach dubai nach dem bus
und dann von polen nach deutschland
gekommen
von irak nach belarus war die reise
offiziell also legal von belarus nach
deutschland war die reise dann illegal
informationen für die reise habe ich aus
feste gruppen ich bin den beigetreten
und habe beschlossen sich anzuschließen
ich habe dafür geschätzt 7000 euro
bezahlt
wir haben gerade nochmal während wir den
ton gehört haben an ihrem ton
rumgeschraubt er war ein bisschen leise
ich meine er ist jetzt laut genug oder
vielleicht sagen sie noch mal
dafür kann keiner was das kann immer
passieren aber jetzt ist es hoffentlich
besser sonst schreibt ihr uns einfach in
die kommentare
ob wir dann noch mal ein bisschen was an
der lautstärke nach oben drehen wollen
jetzt müssen wir aber kurz also wirklich
sprechen es ist sind ja viele
interessante sachen die wir gehört haben
zum einen schon von ihnen und von
mustafa aus dem irak offensichtlich sind
es also wirklich menschen aus
verschiedenen ländern die also dann über
minsk nach polen kommen aber auch erst
mal nach münster das haben sie
geschildert geht es scheinbar über ein
reisebüro und da gibt es eine art
pauschalreise nach minsk und dann an die
grenze verstehe ich das richtig
wie gesagt es ist alles
dabei was man auch als würde hier ist
einen gültigen pass dann kann man der
syrischen botschaft für bis zu 900
dollar verlängern lassen selbst wenn man
eigentlich darin in büchern steht in
syrien das heißt geflogen das waren in
etwa seinen wehrdienst nicht abgeleistet
hat das geht dann trotzdem war das
regime in syrien rock vor allem geld und
das syrische regime wird sicherlich auch
daran verdient dass es diese diese visa
ausstellen genau und dann fliegen die
leute los mit dieser fluggesellschaft
die lage spreche jetzt explizit hierüber
über dem ute bales und dann haut wieder
an und dann ist erstmal mit mehreren
videos gesehen und flughafen wiens
großes chaos da sind dann teilweise
leute die er in der ankunftshalle auf
dem boden kapiert weil viele erstmal
warten müssen da gibt es dann das
prozedere prüfung dieses dieses visums
dieser einladungs briefe und dann müssen
die bürger ich weiß nicht wie es bei
anderen nationalitäten sind noch mal 120
dollar noch mal extra zahlen für habe
visums gefühl oder an hürde was das da
ist ihre handys das fand ich auch so
etwas dann ihre handys müssen da haben
auch registriert werden das sind die
seriennummern und dann kommen die in
linz werden die dann entweder über
individual- transfer oder über busse zu
hotels weitesten in der innenstadt sowie
das recherchiert habe gebracht und da
sind auch fast nur leute aus der
arabischen welt aber auch manche aus
west- und ostafrika
und dann sind die da so etwa sechs trage
das ist im paket inbegriffen weil diese
lange zeit das auch gewollt weil die
lenker die da sind desto mehr geld
kostet das desto mehr verdient dann
nehme mal an der der russische staat
aber auch das hotel daran wer noch alles
und was ich gehört habe jetzt dazu fast
eben tauchen stark aber da kommt
bestimmt welche irgendwie schleuse an
die da aus dem irak kommen aus
bundesstaaten kommen aus syrien kommen
oder aus afghanistan und dann ihre
angebote machen für wie viel geld sie
dann die leute eben zu grenze bringen
und dann auch über die grenze per gps
also handys da darüber
noch ein bisschen was als darüber wie
die migranten sich
organisieren absprechen doch das ist
relativ relativ organisiert aber
sozusagen zwischen den übergoss ab und
über facebook offen es gibt da eine
facebook gruppe ich muss jetzt einmal
dem titel nachlesen der die da heißt
nachrichten für migranten nach wewers
und jahr 22.000 mitglieder
und da werden videos geteilt oder werden
einfach auch so sozusagen packlisten
geteilt also was auch und wenn wir dahin
bei
besorgungen stiefel plane
mehrere mehrere ponys und so weiter und
so fort
zelte und so weiter also das ist alles
dabei was sie auf dieser liste nicht
gelesen haben zum größten schneider das
ist kriegen sie
haben das russische konsulat in beirut
erwähnt dass scheinbar da auch eine
rolle spielt können sie da noch mal ein
bisschen genauer erzählen was sie da
recherchiert hatten
ja da ist eben auch der syrische frank
ohnehin vor ort von von beiden mit weit
in die 90er jahre trotz schöner blick
aufs mittelmeer und dann noch skyline
auch man kommt da an ist eine ganz
freundlichen frau die anfangs jeder um
sgd dann kommt da geht es dann darum
nach wähler wüssten zu bekommen das ist
ein honorarkonsulat das ist alles über
lesen die der arbeit der
honorarkonsul ist so einem foto nach zu
urteilen vielleicht 30 35 jähriger
meister libanesischer christ
da hängt dann alles fördert pixel und ja
man wird den leuten da ganz schnell
vorgebetet wie viel das alles kostet in
die die reise verschiedenen komponenten
des um die reiseversicherung erweiterung
der einladungsbrief und so und der
freund von mir der sagte dass es mit dem
flug immer es geht hier eigentlich nicht
aber ja
es gibt nicht dann können sie das auch
noch nie für ihn buchen und als
erwartet und zwar gerade einer der hat
er doch bei diesen deal abgeschlossen
er war auf dem weg nach draußen da rief
dann diese ist es freundliche
konsulatsmitarbeiter noch hinterher die
pcr test nicht vergisst
vielen dank für wirklich jetzt das
teilen hier von ihrer recherche das
waren sehr interessante einblicke vielen
dank dass sie sich heute abend zeit
genommen haben und falls der touren bis
hin zu leise war ich hab's in den
kommentaren teilweise gelesen wir können
froh sein dass herr schröder uns
überhaupt zugeschaltet war aus beirut
aus dem libanon einem land in dem strom
wirklich mangelware ist also vielen dank
und toll dass das geklappt hat und
wir
und wir sprechen jetzt mit olga drin
doch von der forschungsstelle osteuropa
der uni bremen ihr fachgebiet ist
belarus und mit ihr können wir jetzt
noch einige unserer drängenden fragen
klären auch gerade von euch hier aus dem
streamen und herzlich willkommen schönen
guten abend frau drin doch
günther war wenn sie das so hören also
dass jetzt auch aus dem ausland in dem
falle jens beirut libanon es da also
jetzt eine art professionalisierung gibt
wie man die menschen nach belarus und
dann an die grenze bekommt ist das also
denen da jetzt auch gezielt bei der
einreise weiterreise hilft überrascht
sie das oder finden sie das überhaupt
nicht überraschend
ja was soll ich sagen irgendwie beides
ich meine ich komme ja ursprünglich aus
england ich bin dort aufgewachsen und
das klingt ziemlich schon will seine
journalistische welt erst mal aber
andererseits
spätestens seit dieser geschichte mit
dem rhein er als divine air maschine
gelandet wurde in belarus
muss es uns theoretisch nicht mehr
überraschen also diese stehen jetzt wie
wichtig die macht macht erhalten
lukaschenka ist und dass er alles
mögliche und unmögliche tun kann dass es
weiter so bleibt und leider müssen wir
glaube ich in der zukunft damit rechnen
dass es auch weitere überraschungen
kommen können dass es weitere gefahr
dass sie die europäische sicherheit
entstehen dadurch dass er immer noch an
der macht ist sie sprechen davon dass er
seine macht also lukaschenko der
präsident in belarus seine macht
erhalten möchte aber wie könnte denn
jetzt so einen die stabilisieren der
eu-grenze ihm dabei helfen also wieso
macht er das was will er damit erreichen
also was ich sehe die motivation ist
definitiv nachdem die sektoralen
sanktionen gegen belarus eingeführt
wurden von der eu die ja ziemlich
gefährlich sein können jagd geblasen
schaffen das heißt auch war das budget
woraus auch die gelder für die
unterstützung die ganzen
sicherheitsstrukturen rahmen so weit
dass nach dem diesen funktionen
angeführt wurden
hat er eigentlich auch selbst gesagt ja
das ist auch kein geheimnis dass dieser
reaktion auch in der reaktion auf
sanktionen hat er gesagt dass er
solche sanktion angeführt werden die
grenzen oder mich ehrt belarus die
grenzen zwischen belarus und eu nicht
mehr so
stark stützen würde und dass es dann
tatsächlich passiert vielleicht haben
wir das nicht in so einer drastischen
form erwartet aber es wurde gesagt und
das hauptziel das ich sehe ist
tatsächlich die eu zu spalten weil bis
jetzt hat die eu mit einer stimme
gesprochen was das angeht das heißt ja
wo denn nicht als legitimer präsident
anerkannt und die sanktionen wurden auch
durch alle eu staaten unterstützt und
das dann könnte jetzt sein dass diese
migrations krise die eu spalten kann so
dass einige länder vielleicht dann doch
zu direkten verhandlungen mit
lukaschenko com wenn sie das gefühl
haben dass dieser krise wichtiger ist
als das dass lukaschenko dort nicht als
legitimer präsident anerkannt wird und
das ist natürlich auch
also sollte es dazu kommen dann hätte
dann würde er seine ziele erreichen und
es hier sehen wir das nicht bis jetzt
spricht die ju mehr oder weniger mit
einer stimme aber wir wissen ja nicht
was passiert wenn wir dort nicht über
par tausende vielleicht über zehn oder
hundert tausenden menschen sprechen dann
könnte das schon rund um polen leider
auch anders aussehen und wie es das
einzuschätzen ist das jetzt irgendwie
lukaschenko gegen die eu und gegen alle
oder hat er auch unterstützer
unterstützer in mächtige anderswo die
ihnen da irgendwie den rücken stärken
ich glaube sie haben jetzt russland
gemeint ja klar also generell gesagt ist
lukas schenkel nach den grössten
protesten in der russischen geschichte
die ihr letztes jahr fast ein halbes
jahr stattgefunden haben ist dann der
macht eigentlich dadurch dass russland
in wirtschaftlich und politisch
unterstützt das ist ja ohne frage
eine andere frage ist es für mich ob
alles was von belarus kommt und bedingt
dadurch erklärt werden darf dass es in
russland geplant oder unbedingt
unterstützt wird also wir sehen keine
harte reaktion darauf keine harte
öffentliche reaktion darauf dass
russland es kann sein dass hoch sind da
erst mal kein problem sieht das bedeutet
für mich allerdings nicht unbedingt dass
es von russland oder durch ruß und
erarbeitet wurde oder dass diese
initiative aus russland kommt
gleichzeitig könnte es natürlich sein
das ist auch im interesse von russland
ist das
zwischen davos und die eu keine guten
bedingungen
herrschen
es gibt auch im stream kommentare also
auch jemand der das irgendwie vermutet
hat das vielleicht aber auch der
mächtige freund russland an der seite
von lukaschenko mitspielt und zwar
möchte germain bei youtube wissen
welchen handlungsspielraum wird die eu
wird der eu übrig bleiben wenn der
geopolitische schachzug seitens russland
tatsächlich umgesetzt wird das fragt
germain bei youtube
also wie gesagt ich sehe momentan nicht
wieso aus welchen gründen einer
eskalation diese sind dieses konfliktes
ich meine das kann ja tatsächlich auch
zu einem konflikt kommen wenn dort ja
auch
waffen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen polnischen
belarussischen grenz menschen wenn es
dazu kommt ich meine freundin ist ja ein
nato-mitglied und belarus ist auch in
einen militär bund mit russland und dann
wird auch nicht mehr lustig sein und
ehrlich gesagt sehe ich nicht so ruß und
jetzt sowas brauchen würde also erstmal
werde ich vorsichtig damit zu denken
dass es dort gebrannt wurde wir wissen
das nicht aber wie gesagt so eine
situation so eine information auch
militärs und ich leider nicht komplett
auszuschließen
bis jetzt haben wir aber aus russland
nichts gehört was deuten würde dass es
dass diese rote linie auch für russland
erreicht wurde jetzt geht es ja in
diesem ganzen konflikt nicht nur um in
belarus das geht auch jetzt gerade
umpolen weil da stehen die menschen also
an der grenze wollen da rein und kommen
nicht rein und wie wir am anfang der
sendung gehört haben kommen auch aktuell
hilfskräfte oder journalisten
journalisten gar nicht an die grenze ran
und wie es denn jetzt so ein bisschen
also polens verhalten auch einzuordnen
es gibt berichte über so genannte push
becks also das heißt dass leute die es
über die grenze schaffen sofort wieder
zurückgeschickt werden es gibt berichte
über chaotische zustände gewalt an der
grenze wie ist denn da das verhalten
polens einzuordnen
ja ich meine polen befindet sich
natürlich in einer ganz schwierigen
situation
ich meinerseits diese fußbett die sie
erwähnt haben gleich lang sind uns alle
eigentlich dass menschen
rechtsmäßig ziemlich problematisch ist
ja dass die menschen dort eigentlich
auch schon verstorben sind und dass sie
probleme haben einfach humanitäre hilfe
vor zu bekommen was zum ersten zum
trinken kleidung usw das ist vor allem
nichtregierungsorganisationen
und ehrenamtliche tun allerdings nicht
polnische staatsstrukturen statur
sprach sich jetzt wohl durch die eu als
auch durch internationale
menschenrechtsorganisation
andererseits ist es natürlich auch
verständlich dass kundus durch die ganze
situation einfach genervt ist dass er so
einen druck
druck instrument für lukaschenka
aufholen dass es eine manipulation
und die offizielle argumentation die wir
von polen hören das heißt das land hat
eigentlich verpflichtungen die grenzen
zu schützen
oder dass diese menschen zum beispiel
ganz bei den politischen konsulaten oder
botschaft doch ihre asylanträge stellen
können oder sogar an der grenze aber
nicht überall sondern bei ganz
bestimmten grenzübergangs punkten also
diese argumentation kommt auch aber
insgesamt
deutet polen auch natürlich darauf hin
dass ist bestimmte lücken in der
eu-asylpolitik gibt und das ist
eigentlich stimmt ja auch ja die kennen
ja diese problematik auch schon seit dem
jahr 2015 und das ist jetzt auch keine
neue situation pd ja der einzige
unterschied ist jetzt dass es damals um
griechenland und italien und jetzt jedes
um polen und litauen aber eigentlich die
situation hat er schon erlebt und auch
damals gab es große diskussionen video
was die eu als wenig der krise gelöst
werden soll ich glaub heutzutage es ist
genauso wichtig dass die ohne lösung
findet und wie gesagt mit einer stimme
spricht weil
sonst die situation einfach zu
gefährlich und auch andere länder
könnten da weiß es jetzt erfolgreich ist
könnten da so ein druckmittel als
menschen auch in der zukunft
ich möchte auch mal ein paar kommentare
von unserer community hier einbringen
und zwar michael stehlik bei facebook
schreibt unmenschlich was da passiert
menschen werden als spielball verwendet
markus bei youtube schreibt in erster
linie muss belarus den menschen jetzt
humanitär helfen werde rosat die
menschen einreisen lassen und auf
russischem boden im dreck sitzen lassen
also soll belarus jetzt helfen und
vielleicht noch ein letztes das finde
ich auch interessant was ihr eure
meinung ist pastel kitty bei youtube
schreibt dass menschen im 21 jahrhundert
immer noch als politische objekte
benutzt werden andere politiker dass
auch erkennen ist eine schande dann kann
man doch direkt ein massaker oder
menschenhandel betreiben schreibt
pastell kitty bei youtube die eu haben
sie auch eben angesprochen dass wer denn
jetzt eine angemessene kluge reaktion
der eu weil gerade ist es ja so ein
bisschen alles ein schwebezustand
ja eine lösung habe ich tatsächlich
leider nicht ich glaub
unabhängig davon wie die eu reagiert ist
es wichtig also wie gesagt nochmals
wiederholen es ist wichtig das ist eine
einigung gibt in diese in der lösung
dieser krise innerhalb der eu weil
sollte es zu einer spaltung kommen
solltest das so kommt dass einige länder
dann doch mit lukaschenka sprechen oder
sollte es dazu kommt dass die länder
sich wieder nicht einigen können wird
wie wir es 2015 gesehen haben das wird
natürlich von außen von autoradios
autoritär
auto helfen die den autokratien
entschuldigung also von anderen
autokratien nicht nur von baross von ruß
von und anderen ländern natürlich als
schwächer als externer schwäche der
europäischen union gesehen und das wird
ausgenutzt also wie gesagt die lösung
habe ich nicht am besten sich mich unter
druck zu lassen und besten dann doch zu
einer lösung gemeinsam com und am besten
vielleicht dann doch langfristig an der
allgemeinen asylpolitik arbeiten die für
alle eu mitglieder attraktiv ist und die
zu allen eu-mitglieder passte nicht nur
zu denjenigen die sozusagen kein also
sich nicht an der grenze der jubel in
big ed schreibt dazu bei youtube warum
baut die eu gemeinsam an der polnisch
russischen grenze nicht ein paar asyl
abfertigung ohne stacheldraht und ohne
diese grausamen menschenverachtenden
bilder über die sich russland tod lacht
schreibt dix es ist ein bisschen
vielleicht auch die frage über die wir
noch mal sprechen könnten das ist ja
auch nicht nur die grenze zu polen es
gab jetzt auch von der upe von seitens
der ukraine bedenken ob jetzt vielleicht
sonst sich menschen an einer an einer
anderen grenze auf machen könnten wie
sehen sie denn dann die prognose für die
zukunft bleibt es bei überhaupt bei
diesem wm spielort grenze zu polen
ich glaube solange es so gut sein
einzelnen strich also gut theologe
schenker funktioniert würde er keinen
grund sehen dass woanders zu verschieben
allerdings hat das teil wirklich
mitglied angefangen
litauen ist allerdings viel kleineres
und als polen und dementsprechend ist
dieser grenzlinie nicht so groß
dementsprechend ist es womöglich auch
leichter menschen übergänge zu
kontrollieren im detail als symbolen und
dazu kommt glaube ich auch sehr wichtige
in politische aspekte in polen weil wir
wissen wir dass genau diese
migrationsfrage die polnische
gesellschaft auch sehr stark spaltet und
dass die regierungspartei die gerade in
polen also die partei die an der macht
des dps die natürlich auch diese
situation für eigene
botschaften verwenden die sage ich mal
auch ziemlich migrations feindlich sind
das ganze für kompliziert die in
politische situation in polen und das
ist natürlich leider auch im interesse
von lukaschenko so dass man durch diese
aktion quasi nicht nur eine krise
innerhalb der eu sondern auch eine
ziemlich schwierige politische situation
innerhalb von kuren von daher es ist
leider so dass ich glaube die sollen
schon damit rechnen dass es weiterhin
dortbleiben des angriffs holen
genau aber zu dieser situation dieser
chaotischen an der grenze habe ich noch
eine frage aus dem stream an sie von
sebastian herold der sich fragt könnte
es aufgrund der grenzverletzung durch
belarussische einheiten zu einem
militäreinsatz kommen
das ist genau das was ich auch gemeint
haben dass die situation eigentlich
ziemlich gefährlich ist und es gibt
immer so einen menschen faktor und
niemand weiß ob da irgendetwas irgend so
eine kleinigkeit basiert und die
menschen also begrenzt menschen das dann
doch als gefahr sehen und dann
vielleicht auch womöglich auch schießen
werden und was danach passiert ist
wirklich schwer vorzustellen also wie
gesagt es gibt bestimmte verpflichtungen
von nato zu polen und von russland zum
belarus und
also der konflikt könnte theoretisch
auch weiter eskalieren das ist ein
erfolg und das
dass sich der machthaber in balance
nicht eingeschränkt für das er quasi
nicht so viel mehr zu verlieren hat nach
der mensch als legitim gesehen wurde
nachdem diese fraktion angeführt worden
so das ist nicht mehr nur die gefragte
die belarussische gesellschaft ist
sondern für die ganze regionale
sicherheit in europa und deswegen soll
die eu diese situation sehr ernst trage
bahnen jetzt wurden ja auch immer wieder
über noch härtere sanktionen für belarus
diskutiert wäre das aber auch die
auswirkungen auf die menschen dort vor
ort in belarus wie wäre das von ihrer
seite einzuschätzen wenn es dazu käme
genau also die meisten sanktionen werden
wohl ihre wirkung erst ab dem nächsten
jahr haben und es ist noch zu früh
wirtschaftliche prognose zu machen
allerdings muss sich auch generell sagen
dass solche
außenpolitischen mittel
wirtschaftssanktionen oder sanktionen
gegen ganze sektoren der der wirtschaft
natürlich immer folgen für einfache
menschen haben dass sie einfach nicht
also es ist einfach nicht möglich dass
sie nur das dass das staatliche das
regime oder das staatliche system
treffen sie treffen natürlich irgendwann
auch normale menschen die dadurch dass
wirtschaft leidet auch theoretisch oder
ganz praktisch auch ihre arbeit
verlieren können oder dass ihre gehälter
runtergehen das ist allerdings nicht
bekannt das heißt die politiker die es
tun die sich für sanktionen entscheiden
denke niemand darüber nach was wichtiger
ist sozusagen dann ein auto karten zu
bestrafen und ihnen zu zeigen dass so
was nicht geht oder eben
den menschen da wusste möglich geht so
zügig zu geben weiterhin dort zu
arbeiten wo sie arbeiten und allerdings
gleichzeitig dieser argument genauso von
den russischen von der offiziellen seite
auch benutzt also den menschen in
belarus wird es von staatlichen
fernsehen erklärt dass diese sanktionen
genau gegen menschen gemein sind und
nicht gegen lukaschenka oder sein regime
und das stimmt natürlich nicht aber dass
selbst so dargestellt
vielen dank an dieser stelle für diese
einschätzung für diese interessanten
informationen über thundorfer vielen
dank belarus expertin an der uni bremen
danke heute abend
und natürlich auch vielen dank an euch
in euer interesse und eure fragen und
kommentare und wir behalten das thema
weiter im blick und gehen jeder zeit
natürlich auch wieder live für euch bis
dahin tschüss